this time the indians were no hitted
the next day aaron savali was on the
mound
and so aaron savali tows the rubber
tonight
facing the cincinnati reds for the first
time
in his career nick senzel leading off
the second baseman cesar hernandez had
trouble with it
he recovers just in the nick of time
one down there is jesse winker cracked
his back and a weak roller back to
savali
two down and that'll bring up nick
castillanos
the pitch and he swings and yanks one in
the air weakly to the left
coming in and toward the line to grab it
is rosario
and the reds go in order without scoring
well the indians are going to face a
tough customer who's off to a slow start
luis castille he hasn't been on his game
yet but he's made a few adjustments in
the last few starts
and hopefully he can come out and get a
little bit better than he has pitched
this year
cesar hernandez one two
to first base and bustakas hit a foot
race hernandez
batting left side flying down the line
bang bang
one down for ahmed rosario up and in he
walked him
a rare walk for him ed rosario so the
indians get a one out base runner in
this scoreless first
inning and the batter for the indians
will be jose ramirez switching or
banning left-handed
pitch way down popped tough territory
with the sun of the catch made
going out by farmer and that'll bring up
eddie rosario
castillo's first inning struggles this
year first inning he has an era of 1650
he's given up 14
runs smack to left deep naked back it's
over his head it's going to one hop
defense
flying into third as a med rosario
they're going to wave him home
one nothing cleveland they were no
hitted last night there will be
no no hitter tonight here's franmil
reyes the right-handed hitting d-h
now there's a ground ball up the middle
to his left farmer fields from behind
second throws in time reyes is out the
indians are done in the first but they
get a run
so back-to-back two out singles by
nayquin and stevenson
the reds have a little something cook in
here with two outs and it'll bring up
kyle farmer
in the air center field back goes
rosario
plenty of room inning over no runs two
hits two left
taylor walks second walk dolled out by
castillo is yet to strike a man out
here's jake bowers the left-handed
hitting first baseman
a swing by bowers and a towering fly to
left not deep
naked jogging in there to make the catch
and dropped it now he can't pick it up
in time
and naylor to second and bowers on at
first
as tyler naquin dropped a routine fly
in left holy mackerel are you kidding me
that is just
flat out routine there he bunts third
base side and a beauty
off the mount castillo throw to first he
got him
oh great bunt by austin hedges that's
what's called
fundamental baseball and now the indians
have naylor at third
bower set second one down andre simenes
the number nine hitter and left-handed
hitting shortstop
high fly ball plenty deep enough i would
imagine let's see
naylor tags that's gonna be good he's
under it he's gonna be
here's the throw and it is nowhere near
in time
naylor scores standing two nothing
cleveland gave jimenez his fifth
rbi of the year bases loaded with one
out and now you've got a dangerous man
at the plate the cleanup hitter mike
mustaches
and mustaches reaches for one and pops
it into center field moving toward right
to make the catch the center fielder
rosario
tagging at third since el he scores and
the reds are on the board
sac fly for mustaches makes it 2-1
cleveland two down for a eugenio suarez
high pop-up and savali should get out of
the inning
ximena is calling for it makes the catch
savali does
exactly that he minimizes the damage
reds have five base hits on the night
that brings up the number nine hitter
the rookie
jonathan india fly drive what a catch by
jimenez oh andreas how do you do
what a play to end the inning and the
indians have runners on the corners
with one down put austin hedges coming
to the plate
he bloops one to right field that's
going to get down for a base hit
and the indians extend their lead to
three to one
cincinnati having some defensive miscues
here tonight
that'll be their second error of the
evening and the indians have a great
opportunity here in the fourth to really
open things up
base is loaded one out top of the order
cesar hernandez steps in and a base hit
down the right field line
this might clear the bases it's a
three-run
triple for cesar hernandez
and the indians have blown this one wide
open
six to one tribe aaron savali all of a
sudden with a five-run lead to work with
as we open play in the fifth inning here
comes the 2-2 from savali
fastball called strike three on the
inside corner
second strikeout for savali here's
savali's one two
swung on foul tip was it hung on to you
bet
hedges squeezed it that strike three and
the side is retired hernandez to second
rosario to first and jose ramirez the
batter go for six
in this weekend series hammers that one
to right field
and castiano can't get it let him go to
the wall
two runs are gonna score ramirez
gets up off the deck and delivers a
two-run double to make it eight to one
frannimal with a blast straight up the
gut that's gonna play ramirez
9-1 cleveland aaron sivali
back to work here in the seventh inning
somali's getting better as the game has
progressed
swing and a miss somali strikes out
india
second out fourth strikeout for savali
and strike three call now
since ells not happy somali
his night probably over strikes out his
fifth
and what a job he did through seven
tonight brett's
at the corners one down in the eighth
indians up nine to one
there you go there's one
two inning over nick wick grin on the
pitch
the final winning here's tyler naquin
facing nick wittgen haquin
sends a deep fly ball straight away
center field going back as the center
fielder rosario he leaps and it's gone
tyler naquin with his seventh home run
of the year
takes whittgren deep and it's nine to
two indians and the reds are down to
their last stout
swung on a roller to short gobbled up by
ximena's throw to first
bogey and the indians no hitted last
night
come back in a big way eight out of the
nine
got base hits tonight and the indians
beat up the cincinnati reds